laser pointers are way less safe than  you probably think I bought a bunch of  lasers from Amazon that all claim to be  under five milliwatts anything over that  limit can permanently burn a hole in  your retina so let's compare these cheap  lasers with a proper five milliwatt  laser to see if they're safe  as you can see this green one is  definitely not okay in general Green  Lasers are something I really don't  recommend you buy from Amazon red laser  pointers are better in my experience  especially little ones like this that  are advertised as like keychains or cat  toys rather than like this type  but yeah if you're going to be using a  laser for presenting or experiments or  playing with your cat just make sure it  isn't one that's going to burn someone's  eyes out